Speaker 1: This next video is very
much worth watching. Republicans
seem to be unable to get the hell away
from this AfPak group and conference
led by a white nationalist, Nick Fuentes. And
we talked a couple of weeks ago, I think it was
about Marjorie Taylor Greene speaking at the AfPak
conference, then being told You realize it's a
white nationalist group, right? She said. I didn't
know about that. I was just there because it's
young people with energy and enthusiasm. OK, but
it's happening to many Republicans, and there are
now calls for resignation for the Idaho Lieutenant
Governor McEachern. This is Janice McEachin. She
also spoke at the AfPak conference, and this is
really, really good. She was interviewed by CTV's
reporter Brian Holmes, and he really did a good
job holding her to account. She tries saying,
I didn't know anything about the white nationalist
stuff. And then he says, Well, but so so you're
saying you didn't even investigate it. She gets
into a pickle and she ultimately walks away. This
is really good stuff. Let's take a look.
Speaker 4: Are you familiar with who
puts this event on like Nick Winters?
Speaker 5: I don't. I don't know who he is. I
don't. I've never met him. I don't know who he is.
Speaker 4: Did you not look into it before
you decided to say, OK? Like to find
out? I mean, his name is on it, right?
Speaker 5: Well, you know what, Nick Fuentes,
I don't. As I said, I don't know him.
I he's never I've never met him. I don't
know. You know what? What is what is
everything that he says or does now?
Speaker 1: Every, every conference
that I have spoken out? I don't
meet the organizers often,
but there is no way in hell that I'm going
without doing some serious research into
who's putting this on, and I've turned down
many conferences, not because I personally met
or knew the organizer, but because I knew what
the conference stood for, and I didn't think
that it was a place that I should be appearing.
This gets really good and really tense and say
Speaker 5: is not does not reflect
on who I am or who the thousands of
others that are participating in this movement,
Speaker 4: which look up his name or I didn't say
that. You look, you did lock him up.
Speaker 5:
You didn't. And that's not the
question that you asked me.
Speaker 1: He just asked it, though.
Speaker 4: Did you look up who Nick
Fuentes was and what he what he's talked
about, like what he thinks he has said?
Speaker 5: I have since since last week.
Speaker 4: Not before. Yes. OK. I guess
the question is because if you've said, Well,
Speaker 5: I'm only kidding, it's not fair. I
mean, the mainstream media, you do this to
conservatives all the time, but you don't do
it to yourself that every time, any time there's
any kind of affiliation with anybody at any time
on any stage that we're all guilty by association.
Speaker 1: Really, I mean, I don't remember people
taking this approach when Barack Obama's character
was assailed, because what was it eight years
before he went to? Was it Bill Ayers? I don't
even remember the names of the characters at this
point, but I think it was. He was associated with
Bill Ayers or some church or pastor, something
nobody was saying, Well, come on.
And that was eight years prior.
What they're talking about here was two weeks ago,
Speaker 5: and it's not it's not appropriate.
Speaker 4: But the association is not a good one
to be associated with people who are anti-Semitic.
Speaker 5: Stop. Stop. Excuse me. Excuse me?
Yes. Hello. You asked me why I was there,
what I wanted to participate.
Speaker 1: And she's desperate to control.
She wants to just keep answering one question
and control what it is she's expected to answer.
And it's really a very good job that the
reporter here is doing, and it's not like
Brian Holmes is. I mean, he's doing a great job.
He's not doing anything particularly unusual.
He's just asking very direct questions
Speaker 5: to these young conservatives.
That's that's what we're talking
about right now. Yeah. OK.
Speaker 4: Vincent James is also there.
Correct. Do you know who Vincent James is?
Speaker 5: I I've I've heard of him.
Speaker 4: You've had your picture
taken with him.
Speaker 5: I did have
my picture taken with him. OK?
Speaker 4: Do you know what he
stands for and things that he has said?
Speaker 5: No, I don't know all the things that
he or anybody else. And again, I'm just going to
keep repeating the same thing that this guilt by
association that the media tries to do with
conservatives and conservatives only. That is
Speaker 1: a lie
Speaker 5: is that if we ever have met somebody
once or took a picture with them or
ever shared a stage with somebody, ever,
ever, we're all guilty by association.
Speaker 1: Now understand what she did there.
It is very different to share a stage in a
debate setting where the subject matter is.
That's a white nationalist. I disagree with
them, and I'm making that clear. Then simply
accepting a speaking gig at a white
nationalist conference. Those are two.
Those are not equivalent
in any way. Sharing a stage
isn't actually the issue here, but she knows that
Speaker 5: if you want to know why I went there
and why, what my message was to go watch my
Speaker 4: watch a video and if that's
Speaker 5: what it was all about, if you
Speaker 4: had known who Nick Fuentes is,
would you have said yes?
Speaker 5: Well, again, this this this
movement is so much bigger than one individual
who cares what Nick Fuentes has to say. Who cares?
There's thousands and thousands of young
conservatives all across the country that are very
concerned about what's happening to our country.
Speaker 1: She's really fumbling here,
and it's delightful.
Speaker 5: We are fighting
for the soul of our nation with these wide open
borders. It's only a matter of time that America,
we lose who we are as a free country and so
on. I'm not going to run away. I'm not going to
hide from being being willing and wanting to go
talk to young conservatives about these issues.
Speaker 4: If you say nobody cares what Nick
Fuentes says, but people care that you are
associated with them or that you share a stage
Speaker 5: with, again, you're trying to you're
trying to do this guilt by association. Over
and over and over again. And it needs to stop
because if you want to know who I am and why
I went there, I told you that. And you know,
my don't assassinate me or my character over
something that any individual that I may ever
have met in my life. If there are things and
Speaker 1: again, that's a red herring to
just because you once met someone with a vile view
is different than accepting a speaking invitation
from someone whose movement is what that is that
Speaker 5: are said or that they believe in,
then that's that person. That's not me.
Speaker 4: But that's not the first
time. My point? Bring up Vincent James,
right? You know, that's not the first
time you've been associated with with this group.
Speaker 1: And she just walks away mid-interview.
There we go. She was done with it. So this
entire guilt by association thing no. One,
if you keep associating with horrible people by
choice and then sort of say, Well, I didn't know,
but then when you're asked, had you known,
would you have not gone, then you say, Well,
no, like she's kind of saying, I would have gone
anyway because I was speaking to the conservatives
there who are concerned or whatever. First of all,
they keep associating with absolutely vile people.
And secondly, they do the guilt by association
thing. They did it to Obama. They do it to anyone
who's ever even met a communist or socialist.
I think better said, since communists are quite
rare in the U.S. and they they do it with Black
Lives Matter. They find one person who said,
This is Black Lives Matter, they do it with
Antifa. They do it all the time. Very, very
nice job there by Brian Holmes. And we'll have the
clips up on our Instagram at David Pakman show.